hey guys my name is Jess today it is the
ninth of December and you're watching us
bunnies if you're a halo 5 player you'll
be happy to hear that 343 industries
have you sorted for the holidays to
celebrate the season 3 for 3 are giving
rec packs to anybody with the game to
see if your gift has arrived you can log
into halo 5 or check the ref page on
Halo Waypoint 343 hasn't specified
precisely what fans can expect from
their req pack gifts although they tend
to include things like weapon and armor
skins vehicles and emblems hello Phibes
next expansion the cartographers gift
will introduce forge mode as well as new
multiplayer maps and it's going to be a
free update it appears as if Batman
Arkham Knight developer Rocksteady are
planning to make a multiplayer game
neogaf user nerolac discovered job
listings posted by rocksteady 4 lead and
senior network programming positions the
posting claims that the studio is after
someone with a quote proven track record
as a team lead would experience on at
least two successfully published
multiplayer titles who will manage a
growing team of network coders since the
developer has said that Arkham Knight
will be their last Batman game it's
unlikely that the Dark Knight will have
much to do with a future multiplayer
game palmer square enix bossier each
owada has called konami treatment of
Hideo Kojima cruel and weighed in on the
situation in October it was reported
that Kojima had parted ways with Konami
although the publisher insisted that
Kojima and his team were merely on
holiday more recently Geoff Keighley
revealed that Konami preventive kajima
from attending the game awards and
accepting an award for Metal Gear Solid
5 Yuri ciabatta wrote in a Facebook post
that the whole situation was a negative
cooking on this business adding going
out of your way to make enemies with the
world has no meaning generally this kind
of thing happens when there's a lack of
leadership I think perhaps there isn't
someone in charge who's paying attention
and laying out all the little details
for the whole enterprise when you're not
aware that the feelings of your own
department aren't aligned with the world
at large the results can be
deplorable let me know if you agree with
water down in that comment section and
be sure to head to gamespot where we've
got news on Star Wars 1313 and George
Lucas's take on the force awakens that
is everything I have for you today as
always let me know what you care about
and i'll catch you tomorrow